die polizei hat fünf kinder leblos in
einer wohnung in einem mehrfamilienhaus
aufgefunden
dabei handelt es sich um die mädchen
melina leonie und sophie im alter von
einem zwei und drei jahren sowie um zwei
jungen im dich timo und luca im alter
von sechs und acht jahren
einzig tatverdächtig ist derzeit die 27
jährige mutter der kinder
die mutter der kinder hat insgesamt
sechs kinder
lediglich der elfjährige sohn marcel
lebt der sohn befindet sich derzeit in
obhut der großmutter
dies ist mit dem jugendamt der stadt
solingen so besprochen und vereinbart
vier der toten kinder stammen aus der
ehe der tatverdächtigen zu dem
28-jährigen kinsvater zwei weitere
kinder stammen aus vorherigen
beziehungen der mutter keiner der drei
kind väter ist derzeit tatverdächtig nun
würde ich ihnen gern die gestrige
dynamische und informatorischen sehr
diffuse einsatzsituation den
einsatzverlauf beschreiben
beim polizeipräsidium wuppertal ist
gegen 13 uhr 45
bei der einsatzleitstelle eine
information des polizeipräsidiums
mönchengladbach eingegangen dort hat
sich die großmutter spricht die mutter
der tatverdächtigen gemeldet und
mitgeteilt dass ihre tochter ihr
mitgeteilt habe dass die fünf enkel tot
sei und dass die tochter sich
anschließend auch umbringen möchte
einzig der enkel marcel sei auf dem weg
zur großmutter
dieser notruf war die angeführt beim
polizeipräsidium mönchengladbach
eingegangen
das polizeipräsidium mönchengladbach hat
umgehend das polizeipräsidium wuppertal
informiert polizeikräfte sowie ein
seelsorger zur großmutter einst an die
polizei in solingen hat gegen 13 uhr 50
erste kräfte vor ort an der anschrift
gehabt man hat gewaltsam die tür
geöffnet und dort dann eben die
schrecklichen feststellungen bestätigen
können eine so genannte mordkommission
beim pp wuppertal wurde daraufhin
alarmiert gegen 14 uhr 8 gingen bei uns
der hinweis ein dass der song der so
marcel der für uns noch nicht
lokalisiert war in einem schulischen
gruppenchat mitgeteilt habe dass all
seine geschwister tot sein
gegen 14 uhr 13 hat das polizeipräsidium
düsseldorf dem polizeipräsidium
wuppertal mitgeteilt dass sich eine
weibliche person am hauptbahnhof in
düsseldorf war ein zug geworfen habe
dabei handelt es sich um die
tatverdächtigen die tatverdächtige ist
verletzt und derzeit nicht
vernehmungsfähig
gegen 14.35 konnten wir als polizei
zweifelsfrei feststellen dass der sohn
der 11 jährige bei seiner großmutter in
mönchengladbach eingetroffen ist und
wurde dort unmittelbar von polizei und
seelsorger betreut
gegen 16 uhr hatten wir schließlich den
kind vater der vier getöteten kinder
feststellen können lokalisieren können
und dann auch durch polizeikräfte des
landrats mettmann ansprechen und
betreuen können im gestrigen einsatz am
gestrigen einsatz waren etwa 80
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamte des
polizeipräsidium wuppertal beteiligt
darüber hinaus hatten wir unterstützung
die schon angeführt aus mönchengladbach
aus düsseldorf aus mettmann sowie als
bochum
am heutigen tag waren mehr als 40
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamte im
einsatz
für mich als einsatzleiter sind die
besonderen herausforderung dieses
einsatzes zum einen dass sie auftrage
schreckliche weise fünf solinger kinder
ums leben gekommen sind und dass meine
polizeibeamten die vor ort diese
auffindesituation erleben mussten sowie
die polizeibeamten und polizei beamte
der mordkommission die die tatortarbeit
in der wohnung an den opfern vornehmen
mussten
ein betreuungsbedarf haben daher möchte
ich an dieser stelle allen
familienangehörigen und freunden der
verstorbenen kinder
mein beileid und allen kolleginnen und
kollegen meinen dank und meine
anerkennung aussprechen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren